Search net gear for it's there.
Dump it. It doesn't keep rolling.
There's no hills. Bitch was snow hill.
Fucking worst. Indiana is the
worst state in its own country.
But even in Indiana they found gold
and it became like Qatar or some shit.
They just, you know, they found oil.
They felt like some crazy new patch or
oil and all of a sudden they started
building the world's tallest building
there and all the same kind of shit they
do in Dubai. We do buy
apparently is insane. Now.
They have indoor surfing things in
Dubai in the middle of the day you get a
surfboard and your indoor surfing,
he could ski indoors.
They've indoor skiing and Dubai.
And you're going to have that here in the
compound. Do you have a name for this?
Uh, new, uh, I can't go to pounds
and it's kind of born. Yeah.
And plus I think Anthony [inaudible],
Anthony [inaudible],
who I have to give his props too.
He's probably the reason why I started
a podcast. It was, first of all,
because he was a part of opiate Anthony,
which was the first time
I ever thought like,
I really liked doing radio or the way
opie and Anthony did it. It was great.
We would come in you, you
have done it too, right? Yeah,
but I remember first doing it
going, wow, am I the shitty episode?
Because no one really talked a lot. We
just had fun. I know. I took me a minute.
Oh, they just decided to do what
they wanted to do with radio.
I just thought I was boring because
there's no bells and whistles and fake
laughs and to this day I don't think
opie and Anthony got the credit that it
deserved because I think that they
let us, they let us, they're like,
they're the best show. They were the
best show ever that don't exist anymore,
unfortunately.
But they were the best show ever to
go on as it exist in their own world.
They do.
I know Anthony does and he still has
his therapy brief was recently fired.
I don't, I don't know what, I didn't
know if he started his own thing.
I don't know if he can't have,
Norton is still doing his thing with Sam.
Norton is still doing his thing with
Sam and Norton does a thing with the UFC
too. He does UFC on sensor with
Matt Serra, which is hilarious.
And Norton also does the
chip chip person podcasts.
He does all that on his own now. Yeah.
I've never listened to it, but I've,
I've been tweeted about it enough to know
that it's a character. It's hilarious.
It's so uncomfortable. It's so good. It's
one of my favorite things that he does.
It's fucking amazing. You want to
see a video of it? Go coat. Now
we're in a a live broadcast. No,
but I'll pull it up sometimes.
I hated making people listen to 30
seconds of Cha Cha Cha. There was good.
I liked it. Good. Let people
know. A lot of people don't know.
There's a lot of shit people don't know.
You know,
there's only one way to find out.
Someone has to tell you.
I find out from commercials
that a little help.